Luke here with the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and this week's video has not
quite gone according to plan Jacob
accused me of child abuse
Rebecca's left me my health is taking a
turn and my camping trip to Wyoming
didn't quite go according to plan
[Music]
my face
thank you
[Applause]
you like this Trail no is it really
bumpy yeah
yeah we turn around and go back now or
should we look and see maybe it gets a
little bit better
what do you think
do you want to turn back yes okay 50
tons of bumps up ahead yeah it is really
bumpy isn't it all right bud we're gonna
turn around and go back okay
oh no
did you fall out
you got ran over I don't think you got
ran over I think you just fell off
all right here hop up
Hey Jake do you want to go camping or
you want to go home home home okay I
understand
you want to go do something else besides
camping yeah
yeah
the camping triple was a bit of a bust
and Little Jacob was not having fun so
if I ever want him to go with me again
we need to Pivot well me and Jake are in
the city of Seward and he really wants
to see the aquarium so we're going to
the sea life center does that sound like
fun Jake yeah
[Music]
oh these are big ones
Jacob was that fun yes
[Music]
well who wants me to make some dinner
because I got some camping food that
needs to get eaten are you hungry yeah
we'd like a big juicy hamburger
[Music]
can I go get it
[Applause]
I love it this is the perfect burger
thank you that's that's what Jacob asked
for so catch up on the side Jacob's the
one who asked me to make burgers too
which is
Domino your burger
Nathan's upstairs barfing
a couple rules of making good burgers
first off iceberg lettuce is the lamest
vegetable in the world use butterhead
lettuce Romaine spring greens anything
but Iceberg number two toast the buns
with butter and a little bit of garlic
powder if you want cook it until the red
sweat just barely stops coming out you
don't want to overdo it Hey Jake you
want to roast marshmallows
all right let's build a fire
oh Tommy you grab some sticks for us
thank you bud
you got to do much harder
oh there you go got it okay you wanna
take it here and they'll put it shove it
in the bottom there I think you did it
bud
move this over here
so we got marshmallows with chocolate
inside and then we've got chocolate
vanilla pudding cups so we're gonna take
some chopsticks
and free dang it
okay
the gel kind of cools the outside
because it doesn't burn your mouth it
tastes really good
look at that
thanks Dad you like the jello on it
you guys like your sugar with a little
extra carcinogen in it yeah we go we got
we could hook you up I've got a Chinese
marshmallow sticks
what do you think of the jello is it a
nice touch absolutely fantastic all
right you guys take care thank you so
much
roasting marshmallows with the neighbors
that's nice
let's get it let's get in our sleeping
bags and watch a movie shall we
lower off
wilkin's been throwing up and Jacob has
explosive uncontrollable diarrhea it
smells so bad in here I took the first
pass it was rough
underwear is cheap people just throw it
away
parenting is not for the squeamish
smells bad this smells better yeah well
it looks like the outdoor boys are gonna
be inside today so that's all right I
got a lot of work to do Jake did you go
to the bathroom
did you poop your pants
yes welcome to my workstation when I'm
not out camping or in the garage
cleaning this is what I'm doing in order
to get you guys one video a week I work
about 70 to 80 hours a week on average
for 120 minute video there's usually two
days of filming one day of editing one
day of packing and getting everything
ready one day of cleanup and downloading
and all that and then also planning
about five five six days to do one 20
minute video and when I do these really
big videos it takes a whole lot more
time so not too long ago I posted a one
hour video of our entire trip of the
Southwest United States so that video
took about two two and a half months of
work in preparation you guys doing okay
in here yeah yeah that's clean that's a
good sign yay so right now I'm working
on editing a trip we took to Hawaii we
spent two weeks filming in Hawaii and it
was a wonderful trip except that my
camera got cracked underwater and the SD
card got compromised with salt water
water and it caused me to lose three
days worth of footage after spending
three thousand dollars on data recovery
services I got about thirty percent of
my footage back so now I have one
terabyte of data and it's going to take
me an entire week to edit it but in
addition to that I'm missing major
portions of the entire video and I've
got to figure out how to piece that
together to make some sort of sense out
of it I've been picking at this a little
bit at a time for almost two months now
now the worst part about this is that I
injured my right arm a couple years ago
building my log cabin and whenever I sit
here at my desk and work this mouse and
keyboard for hours on end it flares up
and hurts bad but when I feel like I
need a little bit of break from editing
I'll work on planning future videos I've
got almost half my videos planned out
for the entire summer me and Nathan are
gonna rent a boat and try to fish and
camp on the Inside passage of Alaska we
got a two and a half week trip to Japan
that I'm like 95 done planning this
morning I spent about three hours
working on renew our global entry and
TSA pre-check for the entire family so
that's been a major headache and it's
not done yet I'm gonna have to go down
to the airport to finish that so that's
a little sneak peek at what it's like
behind the scenes to plan out all these
videos oh I'm tired
hey Tom how was school bud good
hey babe how you doing the kids leaking
at all hey Nathan you feeling better
[Music]
anything come out uh no no you must be
better how was school you guys have a
good time at school bye you guys I mean
Tommy because everyone else was pooping
and throwing up
you can just feel myself getting a cold
it's gonna be one of those days
oh well to make matters worse today's
the day Becca's leaving me everyone knew
it would happen eventually go surprise
my mom for her birthday she
I mean but I
thought of course it's too late for me
Becca the germs have me save yourself
love you
oh
the next day
I think me and Jacob got a pair of man
colds
you know things on this trip haven't
quite gone according to plan
and I thought maybe you guys would enjoy
seeing some other trips where things
didn't quite go according to plan here's
some footage from a winter camping trip
to Wyoming that me and the family took
it was fun but it didn't quite go right
Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel I'm here in the mountains of
Wyoming and it's negative 27 degrees
and I'm camping
[Music]
[Applause]
all right Becca we packing
let's do this thing
all right
here hold dad
I do your luck wow that is really good
oh
nice baby
love you baby
this tastes like strawberry ice cream
it's amazing
[Music]
here come on in guys
don't need coats you want to kick off
your shoes
hey guys what do you think do you like
this I love this well we spent about six
hours in the car but we finally made it
to taguari Lodge here in Moran Wyoming
and it is bitterly cold outside and it
is supposed to drop another 20 degrees
oh oh yeah let me get some snuggles here
that is not even low death we gotta go
to dinner we've laid here too low get
dressed get dressed
all right let's go
everybody out everybody
got a nice little buffalo burger here
yeah that's too bad
all right guys let's get everyone to bed
we got a lot of stuff
get to bed we got a lot of snow
Machining to do in the morning
get to bed all right guys we'll see you
in the morning we're gonna have a lot of
fun good morning everyone everybody
all right should we go outside and see
what the thermometer says
yeah it is negative 22. I can always
tell when it's below negative 15 because
when you breathe in it makes the boogers
in your nose freeze
okay car doesn't want to start we'll
just go to walk
there you go you want to scoot in so
other people can sit
still way down
oh my goodness you gotta eat up build up
fat reserves
hot chocolate bacon you want me to go
warm up the pickup truck and bring it
around
okay
all right we're gonna see if we can get
the truck started this time
look at that that spot of gas pedal all
the way to the floor it's all they do in
2000 RPMs she is sluggish but she's
going hey good looking you want a ride
is it cold outside yes
oh check it out
negative 27.
well my kids may not ever go outside
again they are not a fan of this and we
really don't have our best gear either
so it's it's all of our really good
gears in Alaska so I'm gonna go and get
all bundled up all of my gear all the
hand warmers and uh we're gonna do a
little snow Machining
all right Tom
[Music]
how you doing your good
I can get those boots off get those
boots off maybe I do the laces first All
Right Aid come on get dressed get
dressed
you ready
they're open the door there yay
[Music]
yeah
he likes it
all right should we go get some lunch
let's go we're originally gonna go and
snow machine out into the mountains and
camp for two days but uh the snow
machine company said oh no you can't do
that even though I talked to them
beforehand so
we're just gonna kind of have to do a
plan B and I can't do plan B's on an
empty stomach so I'm gonna go get some
lunch with the family and we're just
gonna see what happens
oh that's him right there
yeah it's cold out there isn't it it
looked like one of our boys just shed
their skin like a snake look at that
well I got lunch out of the way I think
it's time to go camping I need to start
packing up
I love you be safe that is so cool
I love you
oh
stay warm
so I ended up sending the snow machines
back early canceling my rental and uh
I'm gonna go snowshoeing then I just
rely on my own two feet today I'm
actually glad to be doing a little
walking because it is bitterly cold it
hurts your lungs and teeth to breathe
the air without a mouth covering it's an
aggressively cold day
I think I'll head off that direction
there's some fluffy powdery snow I could
also almost stay on top of the snow
but my backpack could be just a hair too
heavy
check this out I got an owl hole see
those prints in the snow right there the
owls have such great hearing they can
hear the mice burrowing under the snow
and they'll swoop down and pluck them
through the top of the snow you can see
where his wings hit the snow
you know the phrase fast is slow and
slow is fast if I go slowly I don't sink
as much and it takes a lot less effort
and time I try to be more aggressive I
think way down
originally the whole family was going to
come camping with me we're gonna have a
nice family winter camp out but we had a
storm come in and it dropped to negative
27.
and my wife doesn't do negative 27 so
her and the kids are warm in the cabin
yeah my wife's always been the smart one
is looking like a pretty nice spot to
camp a lot of trees to block the wind
but not too many trees so there's lots
of nice flat spots to set up a town
okay maybe right there
when you get a whole bunch of fresh snow
in very cold conditions you get this
champagne powder that we have here and
it just doesn't have any structure to it
it's just fluffy so I'm using my
snowshoes to pack down a little platform
for my tent give me a place to work
without wallowing in the snow all the
time I could dig down but I'm afraid I'm
going to hit all these saplings and
those could put a hole in the bottom of
my tent so I'm just gonna compact the
snow instead
Standard time I'm using is made by Nemo
and it's a Four Season backpacking
two-person tent it's kind of rare to get
a lightweight cold weather tent it's not
the warmest tent in the world but it's
one of the few cold weather tents
that'll fit in the backpack
foreign
getting all my gear ready and just
kneeling on this ice freezes me to death
so I just sit here and I got my sleeping
bag and using it as a kneeling pad and
just little tricks like that will do
wonders to keeping you warm
self-inflating mats really don't work at
these temperatures the plastic gets too
stiff so you really end up having to
blow it all up most name brand mats come
with these inflating sacks nowadays and
using these inflating sacks will save
you a lot of energy
[Applause]
so my camera's set up for filming at
night nothing more wonderful than taking
off your gloves at negative 20 to touch
metal GoPro mounts I need to take a
second to get feeling back in my hands
my fingers aren't working so hard
okay got some unleaded gas in my bottle
here
get some more snow
oh nice hot cup of tea sounds pretty
good to me
I'm gonna sit in my herbal tea right
there in the pot so it doesn't cool off
too quickly while it's steeping
ah
but I think I'm gonna boil up some more
water and get some dinner cooking
spilled gasoline all over this log you
know gasoline can be pretty dangerous
but at this temperature it's not that
volatile it just doesn't want a light
look at this
have you ever seen gasoline ignite so
lazily
all right for dinner I've got some
coconut chickpea Curry and boiling bag
of rice it's delicious it's cheap it's
easy
there we go just let that sit for about
11 minutes and we're good to go
oh it's minus 20. you got to eat your
food quick otherwise it's going to be
cold
oh that was delicious but my hands are
frozen it's so cold out here I can only
work with my hands for about three four
minutes before they're just absolutely
numb and I gotta pull them into my
gloves and warm them up I'll tell you
what I'm getting pretty cold I'm gonna
make up a hot water bottle try to warm
myself up a little bit
oh man look at that water my pot froze
solid just in that short time it is cold
come on look at that my water bottle is
Frozen it's made the end bulge outwards
so it take some work to get this all
thought out
there we go see we can melt that
I can't believe Becca and the kids
didn't want to join me on this campout
I wonder if they're having any fun
without me
[Music]
I think I might try to make a little
warming fire it can't be much there's
not a lot of dead wood around here
thank you
I got a cotton ball with some Vaseline
on it and some wood shaving soaked in
paraffin we're gonna put that
right under there and it's cold nothing
wants to light on fire everything is
cold
there's just not enough big fuel around
here to build a proper warming fire but
a little something like this can be
enough just to get you the feeling back
in your fingers
and get your temperature up just enough
that you can hop into your sleeping bag
with a warm body instead of a cold one
you can get a hot fire with all these
little sticks they'll just spend all of
your time tending it and gathering
firewood it'll just burn through the
woods so quick
oh that feels good
oh that's nice
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I'm using my meager pile of firewood
as a seat here you can kneel on it and
not have my body straight on the eyes
helps a lot I'll tell you what guys I'm
starting to have some real doubts about
this campout the temperatures just
dropping and it can get down to negative
30 tonight it's a lot colder than I was
anticipating and I'm just not prepared
for that you know I don't think I'm
gonna die or anything but I think I'm
just going to be shivering in my
sleeping bag all night long and you know
what I'm getting too old for that stuff
you know I think I'm just gonna leave my
gear all right here another one's gonna
bother it tonight
and I'm just gonna hike out of here you
know without my backpack on I know I can
make pretty good time and I can follow
my tracks really easily out of these
Woods even in the dark yeah I think
that's what I'm gonna do I've been
boiling this pot for 45 minutes I've
used up almost half my fuel and it's
still not even close to Boiling it's
barely melted I am not going to have
boiling water tonight
well one nice thing about this is it's a
lot easier to hike out than it is to
hike in I've already broken trail and my
path freezes up as it gets cold
hey
I have gold yeah I gotta get my
snowshoes off ah the weather was too
cold and my wife's too hot it's just a
combination for coming home
just things weren't clicking right I'm
gonna put this camera down and get some
of these clothes off oh good morning
family
oh this was so much better than
hypothermia all right well I'm up and
about and I've got to get all these
clothes back on my body and go hike back
out get my stuff
all right everything looks okay
let me give you a closer look at this
tent there's a couple things that make a
Four Season tent a Four Season tent
first off instead of a bunch of mesh
it's solid material you don't have
nearly as much ventilation Additionally
the rain fly will go all the way down to
the ground none of this like mini skirt
rainfly nonsense another thing you'll
notice with four season tents is they're
small the smaller the tent the warmer
the tent
you know this video has been kind of an
interesting one a lot of prep planning
goes into these videos I've been working
on this one for two months
for me and the family we've had a good
time despite all the chaos and we're
determined not to let it ruin our fun so
we're gonna try to get out of here early
and see if we can't do some more fun
stuff
ice possible
yeah you think
all right has everyone had a good time
yeah yeah I'm jumping on oh check it out
there's a badger I see him
everybody who was excited about seeing
you Badger raise your hand yeah
yeah guys here so I got a chocolate
Nutella banana bread
got a maple scone eggnog orange zest
pastry of some sort it's good oh this is
bread pudding French toast I think
that's Apple Syrup and Honey butter
right there I think wow how many meals
did I buy okay I panicked bought a few
salmon
Lunchables the second right onto East
for 11. I think next time we're in
Jackson Hole we might have to hit
Persephone's again
well guys I hope you enjoyed these
videos and got a little bit of a sneak
peek what things are like and uh
hopefully if your family camping trips
don't quite go according to plan you
won't feel so bad it's
happens to all of us at any rate I'll
see you guys next Saturday click
subscribe and all that
yeah if you like this video don't forget
to check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button and you'll get notifications
thanks for watching